wir haben heute besuch von sophie in
bonn wo kommt ihr her
wir kommen aus australien und was macht
ihr in berlin
wir machen eine art gaskocher ja und wie
gefällt euch berlin bisher hier ist sehr
interessant und es macht so etwas
die beiden haben uns geschrieben und
heute machen wir ein video zusammen zum
thema was hat dich zum lachen gebracht
dann gucken wir mal vorüber die
deutschen so lachen oder auch nicht los
geht's
[Musik]
was hat dich heute zum lachen gebracht
die karte sowieso medikation hatte und
wach war und in der küche eingeschlossen
war dass ich mit ihnen unterwegs bin
wir sind unterwegs zusammen ist sehr
lustig mein frühstück ja wieso sehr gut
und ich auch das richtige wort und
kaffee frühstück
wir waren gerade im mauerpark und haben
uns dort ein gedicht schreiben lassen
und haben uns sehr gefreut und mehr was
weiß ein gedicht über unsere familie
ich übernachte aber ist die besucher in
berlin und ich konnte die nacht nicht so
gut schlafen und habe mich dann zu einer
mitbewohnerin von ihr ins bett gelegt
weil es warm war und eng und dann kamen
sie heute früher ein und sollte gucken
ob ich noch da bin und dann muss ich
lachen nachrichten aus meinem klassen
chat auf rezept da waren ein paar sehr
lustig meine freunde nennen mit denen
ich heute unterwegs wenn wir haben drei
worte dem dichter gegeben und er hat in
zehn minuten ein gedicht über unsere
familie geschrieben für die lücke ist
das ist unser familienname ein tag im
mauerpark mit deinen lieben reise bienen
mach dich stark ob die sonne scheint
oder der himmel vereint sind die lücke
des vereins gibt es nichts in der welt
dass sie traurig stimmen könnte weil
ihnen fast alles gefällt was sie sehen
wenn sie zusammen sind weil sie sich
gegenseitig verstehen und stets zusammen
halten egal wohin sie geben das ist ein
schönes gedicht ja noch nicht
du gerade jetzt you are making händler
was hat dich heute jung machen gebracht
mein frühstück etwas lustig weil wir
haben zusammen gefrühstückt und zwar
lecker und deswegen sind angebracht die
lena heute früh ja ja sie hat so lange
gebraucht
mindestens eine halbe stunde meine
freundin heute morgen die heute morgen
shoppen gehen wollte
wieso weil heute sonntag die geschäfte
haben zu halo kannst du dich eine
geschickte für mich schreiben
hast du drei worte für mich ja natürlich
deutsch lernen straße gehe dankeschön
dann gib mir fünf minuten zeit ich lass
mir was einfallen was hat dich heute ist
im lachen gepackt wir schauen heute
schon so einige sachen zum lachen
gebracht und zwar das erste was man
schon zum lachen gebracht hat war glaube
ich mein bruder als er gesungen hat ja
wieso aber weil er ganz lustige die da
sind wir ganz lustig klingt manchmal das
ist ja ein glücksrad dreht materialien
dann muss man verschiedene aufgaben
machen dass jeder von uns dabei hat
sagen gedreht und hat dann etwas gemacht
was da je nach dem was da drauf steht
[Musik]
was hat dich heute ist im lachen
gebracht
die katze eines freundes von mir super
süß ist und die ganze zeit auf dem
balkon herumklettert und danach sind
auch geklettert ist aber nicht mehr
runterkamen und wir dann alle zu dritt
versucht haben diese katze wieder runter
zu bringen das hat mich zum lachen
gebracht was hat dich heute ist zum
lachen gebracht
eigentlich noch gar nichts ja oder der
letzte mal mensch ärger dich nicht
spielen kannst du der geschichte für uns
lesen
na klar deutsch lernen straße leer
ausgehe hinaus auf die straße und rede
mit den leuten mit den vielen wilden
leuten die sich an diesem milden winter
tag am wetter erfreuten und ebenfalls
nach draußen gingen um zu lachen und zu
singen
trau dich und spricht mit ihnen in ihrer
muttersprache
dort wo sie toben und lernen wenn du
deutsch lernen willst
danke schön dass so viel wie schreibt
man das ja ja ja und und brawn und
janosch warst du überrascht worüber die
deutschen so gelacht haben zum beispiel
über ihre katzen oder gefrühstückt über
das frühstück war ich schon ein bisschen
überrascht ja und sonst habe ich mir im
wie immer übrigens gedacht na ja die
frage ist doch nur ein anlass und etwas
witziges zu erzählen und das jetzt weiß
oder nicht war egal hauptsache irgendwo
ein witz darüber und die deutschen den
zellen amaras die sache und wie die
sache ist und ernst und ehrlich und ganz
wunderbar ich lieber die deutsch
dankeschön jannis darüber freuen wir uns
sehr
und ihr könnt jetzt auf jeden fall noch
interaktive übungen machen vokabeln und
das transkript
zu diesem video bekommen das ganze ist
möglich wenn ihr ein mitglied werdet von
easy german ihr seid sozusagen ein
mitglied in unserem privaten club damit
helft uns dass wir dieses projekt
professionell betreiben können und
gleichzeitig könnt ihr auch intensiver
deutsch lernen hier könnt ihr einfach
mal drauf klicken weil katrin werdet ihr
ein mitglied und hier könnt ihr sie
german abonnieren damit ihr immer
benachrichtigungen bekommt wenn ein
neues video draußen ist was war das
es war die teams bis zur nächsten woche